[Applause]
for Tabloid fter she's a keeper but what
if Taylor's stories went much deeper
welcome to part one of our 56p part
series can we please never stop talking
about Taylor Swift where each panelist
picks a news story and links it back to
Taylor Swift Tyrus you go first I just
like to say up until this point I'm
being forced against my will ladies and
gentlemen you noticed in the highlights
there was never once me mentioning that
the name I shall never
speak but apparently I don't get paid
unless I do this so all right so uh
Toyota issues a do not drive advisory
for 50,000 car owners over potentially
deadly airbag issues because the car
will not operate unless you download
Taylor Swift's latest album so the only
way you can drive safely is if by you
downloading downloading a Taylor Swift
album that's the only thing the cars you
don't need electricity you don't got to
plug them in just the sweet sounds of
her
music now there was a couple of
accidents because they tried to use
other singers to get the cars to work
they tried John Mayor they tried uh what
was it Jonas brother yeah and then Kanye
West none of those worked yeah but Swift
did yeah because they're you know they
used to date her yeah not Kanye no Kanye
didn't date her but he dissed her at the
MTV Music Awards so he's on the list God
I totally went over my head Joe well
this is the first I'm hearing about this
young lady so I'm not sure exactly who
she is but in uh Banbridge Georgia uh
there there's controversy someone uh
drug Company's trying to open up a
monkey Farm oh to get your fresh monkeys
yeah in Banbridge Georgia 30,000 monkeys
and it's like they say if you take
30,000 monkeys put them in a room with
typewriters eventually they would have
written a Taylor Swift album oh
wow
let's hope she doesn't try to date them
I I feel bad for imagine you had date
her and you break up that's bad enough
and then it's a hit song You have to
hear about your breakup being happened
to me all the time Kennedy well I'm glad
you asked Greg uh the United Parcel
Service also known as UPS slashing
12,000 jobs uh in order to save a
billion dollars they had a horrible 2023
it's been bad the first part of this
year and it's because all the people who
spent thousands of dollars to see Taylor
Swift on her ays tour uh they could no
longer afford Christmas presents to send
to their family so they stopped going to
UPS and instead of sending those
presents they've now sat around for so
long these people are starving they are
now eating the Christmas presents that
were intended for beloved friends and
family members coincidentally yes UPS is
saving a billion dollars how much did
Taylor Swift make from her ays tour $1
billion interesting a coincidence I
don't think so stop the steal is it a
swifted swifted it's that's good all
right close it out cats okay so Coast
Guard seized 55 million bucks worth of
coke and weed MH and Taylor Swift gave
everyone who worked on the AOS tour 55
million exactly in bonuses
really so my brother and I our birthdays
are 10 days apart so what we always used
to do is we'd say why don't we pull our
birthday money together and get
something big like we get like an N64
and then my sister would be like you we
can't play it cuz you don't have to pay
for it but whatever um that's what they
did they're like listen this isn't that
much money here but if we buy like
10,000 lbs of drug yes and then we sell
it then it's way more so they try to
create I will say a small business
actually like bigger than small with
that amount of drugs
um and it didn't really work out for
them that is a great story yeah exact
same amount clearly everyone on the air
enough to get you through her tour drug
together I'm going to say this is my
favorite segment of all time all right
I'm not kidding either don't go away
we'll be right back hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else